this is what we've been sent back we
were told that this is a hallmark in
human history at first glance that it
doesn't strike me as particularly
illuminating right right but you have to
remember that this is the first really
good photo of a world that we're all
quite familiar with we all remember as
childhood learning about the ninth
planet Pluto but really it's just been a
point of light to us before or remark on
a star charts for 85 years but now here
it is revealed in detail and tomorrow
assuming all goes well and the images
come back we're going to see it in at
least 10 times this level of detail take
us through the journey that new horizons
as embarked upon we're talking about
launched in 2006 it takes four and a
half hours for the information to reach
us back here and that gives you an
indication of just how far away put to
it Pluto is a very long way away it's
really hard to imagine but but even at
its closest to the Sun it's still about
30 times further from the Sun than the
earth is so as you say Pluto launched
back in 2006 in 2007 it made a close
approach to Jupiter that's pretty much
on our doorstep relatively speaking and
since then it's just been sailing out to
this outer region of the solar system
that we call the Kuiper belt to visit
the most significant object actually the
largest we now know object in the Kuiper
belt which is Pluto which also it sounds
to teach us a lot about a world that we
already feel like we know a little bit
even if we haven't actually got that
much information about it yet it's you
know it's going to be an explosion of
information over the next few days but
it's not just the Pluto that we'll be
learning about as you mentioned the
Kuiper belt but also one of the moons
Chanin's well we're going to be so
that's right actually all of the moons
of Pluto Pluto has five known moons
we've got Karen which is the largest one
significant one and then more recently
we've got Stix Nix Hydra and kerberos
which are all much smaller I'm certain
thing a mythological nadie this is
within the mythology of the Roman
underworld where where Pluto is that the
god of the Roman underworld and so all
these moons are very appropriately now
now they're much much smaller Karen and
Pluto certainly the significant ones but
actually studying the composition of
these smaller moons will help us to
understand more about the evolution of
the Pluto system which seems to have had
quite a complicated past now explained
to us that the probe itself near horizon
says has gone dark at moment we're not
heating anything from it what why is
that right so if you actually look at
images of the probe you
it's got a very big antenna all in a big
big radio dish and the radio dish can't
be can't be moved separately from the
spacecraft so the spacecraft is covered
with instruments they're all pointing
out in different directions and what the
spacecraft has to do is actually turn
itself around to point the cameras at
Pluto Karen and the other moons of Pluto
and in the process the antenna has to be
pointed away from the earth so the
spacecraft has gone dark it's been given
this predetermined flight plan to carry
out and hopefully we're going to get a
phone home a little bit after midnight
tonight our time when the spacecraft
will begin to downlink that is to send
back the high-resolution data and this
high-resolution data man information
we've had up until now has been limited
to a few pixels across essentially but
this high res data giving us an insight
into the origins of the solar system
itself absolutely so we think the Kuiper
belt is our relatively untouched and
almost primordial part of the solar
system it's so far away from the Sun
that much of the chemistry and the
Kuiper belt hasn't been destroyed by
solar radiation or affected so the
Kuiper belt actually teaches us what the
solar system what the inner solar system
may once have been like and that kind of
helps to fill in some of the gaps about
our knowledge of the formation of the
solar system but also there's this
really interesting idea that Pluto's a
bit of a treasure trove of secret
geology and secret features that have
never been seen before and I think we
stand to find that they're going to be
very interesting very unusual and
perhaps quite colorful the fingers
crossed tom curse from the Royal
Observatory thanks very much attack
thank you